les amis merci d'avoir étalé tout sur
arte demain n'oubliez pas la télé c'est
que de là et alors là on a ce qu'on
attend nation l'attendait et tpm paix
rhdp et oui parce qu'alors on a appris
qu m6 bosser sur une version de tpm paix
vaart est aussi ils ont carrément pris
fin il ya m6 tout mon team et tout le
monde est fou ces personnes mais
n'auront jamais l'alsace et la lorraine
alors artisans fin pilotes cyril je
passe vous saviez non on vers une
émission qui testent un ctp mp3 les
versions arte avec de la culture et tout
à l'intérieur
j'en ai dit assez ressemblants regarder
cet égard on regarde
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur l'entrée
dans touche pas mort j'ai bien merci
d'echery vous étiez 42 à nous regarder
hier soir on a battu notre record où
tout de suite se sont rebellés mission à
notre invité joseph salma est courtois
directeur de l'opéra franc fort j'adore
1 vous le savez c'est mon bébé va y
avoir de la cadart je le sens qu'a
d'arcade arcade d'art on va s'éclater
autour de la table jean louis
d'hortensias kate avec le directeur du
cnrs géré lui le mois de sa maman bébé
et directeur du cabinet du ministre de
la culture marie annick du ventre eu de
télérama et mon chouchou et loulou
joachim lou doillon pio tekere bien sûr
chez les ados routage sms de mahler
alors mes bottés on va un petit peu se
détendre tout marie-annick vous avez un
coup de coeur et alors là c'est chez
vous là cette vidéo j'ai eu la chance de
l'avoir avec l'artiste que nous
connaissons tous et que nous chérissons
vladimir poutine
j'ai beaucoup aidé c'est qui de plus
drôle que lui pour nous délivrer cette
vidéo que nous allons nous délecter
regarder les regarde et je vous jure ça
c'est magnifique sans déconner c'est
magnifique par mois là plus personne en
régie personnes arrêtées
allez c'est pas grave tout c'est la
cabine abl
aucun déchet et je sais que vous
l'adorez c'était pour avaya nordine qui
me le dit dans l'oreillette c'est ça
vous devinez qui est derrière le rideau
alors d'après vous est-ce que c'est un
chevreuil qui se prend un doigt dans le
cul par philippe candeloro sergei pop
allofs le danseur étoile tchécoslovaquie
et à la scala de milan
lucas reste demain je place mes bébés à
la maison vous allez être comme des
dingues je le sais puisque c'est ça
vous avez mon bébé c'est mon bébé tu
nous fait une petite démo du spectacle
c'est parti je ne sais pas si les
téléspectateurs afin de contrer on
ressent vraiment toute la souffrance de
son peuple tout en gardant la grâce d'un
signal studios hashtag #civsocial un
signe c'est parti vous rajouter vos
boucles auteurs les amis merci d'avoir
été avec nous sur arte merci à vous
demain n'oubliez pas la télé c'est que
de la sueur c'est la merde
[Applaudissements]
du ciel
the guardian